hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday September 23rd 2019 what's
going on yes the summer is officially
over you guys can all now cry that it's
[ __ ] over and it's still [ __ ] 70
degrees out anyway I hope you enjoyed
your summer football season is is is you
know we're still in September so it goes
by quick everybody talks about you know
raising a kid how fast it goes by and
there's a million people that will warn
you how fast raising a kid I said I
turned around and all of a sudden he had
a beard and he was coming at me with a
knife
I was just like I used to change your
diapers and he was like I act right
everybody talks about how fast that
journey is ad nauseam right something
using that correctly but nobody but
nobody ever tells you how fast football
season goes by nobody warned you you
know they get you all excited what and
all of a sudden they're looking at the
playoff picture what the [ __ ] happened
you know you lose your shirt betting in
the beginning because you don't know
who's good your bet in college football
what the [ __ ] you're doing laying 60
points in September whatever the [ __ ]
these stupid games are then you start
figuring it out right around when they
start wearing the pink and next thing
you know it's [ __ ] Thanksgivings
coming up Jesus where we going you're
how yo can we go to my family right you
have that big [ __ ] fight I will I
will stay here yeah you guys could all
go you gotta give a [ __ ]
that's not true I love the holidays
right he had that big stupid fight by
then you like there's like [ __ ] four
month left and yet better that pep-pep
bad damn what a that but maybe that's
what it is I used to think it was
because there was so few games in the
year that it just flew by that's not
what it is it's because you get like
halfway through this season and then
it's just [ __ ] holiday season even
though everybody looks past Halloween
you know except for the gays right
they're the ones they're the only ones
out there they'd understand the
importance of the Halloween right
everybody [ __ ] blows by it it's a
great excuse to make some pumpkin bread
you know start getting the whole [ __ ]
holiday look around your apartment your
house so you get tent wherever the [ __ ]
you're at actually you wouldn't need if
you live in a tent the [ __ ] foliage
is you're sleeping on it I don't think
homeless people are too excited about
the what is that pumpkin [ __ ] they put
in everything and like you know those
[ __ ] attics so go down to the [ __ ]
Starbucks and stand in a line of 40
[ __ ] people to get their fixed in the
morning they always have those pumpkin
infused lattes you know who doesn't want
one of those [ __ ] things if somebody
living outside during Halloween you know
do you think anybody knocks on their
tent see if they got any candy they can
give up no bill that's mean oh maybe it
is maybe this I don't know what but then
you know and then it's [ __ ]
Thanksgiving right and then it's [ __ ]
Kristin it you know other I guess like
football I mean sorry hockey and
basketball but it's the beginning you
get it out of the way and they play a
zillion games that's what I think that's
what it is it's there's so few games the
holidays takes up like [ __ ] you know
60% of the goddamn season I feel like is
the if you don't cut the playoffs
alright half the season what I would
know I was never good at math I was good
at regular math plus/minus divide
multiply can do that [ __ ] all day you
okay you need me to map out how to make
a [ __ ] bridge I'm sorry it's it's not
okay so stop with the emails I can't
help you I think that's what it is so
I'm really trying to [ __ ] and enjoy it
and what I'm doing is I'm just taping
games I'm taping games because I got to
do other [ __ ] on Sundays I go to a
farmers market that's what I do I go to
the total dad guy I load up the whole
family we go down there we get the
fruits and vegetables that are allegedly
organic but we all know came from from
some [ __ ] evil farm okay and you know
they just got some [ __ ] you know meth
heads down there running the [ __ ]
table that they're like listen just say
it's organic and we'll give you the meth
after after all right you see them all
sweating you think it's because they
just pulled you know we're working hard
pulling the crops out of the ground it
isn't they're just feeding for more meth
but whatever I like a lie like anybody
else you know so I go down there we do
our [ __ ] thing got a bunch of
vegetables and all that [ __ ] little bit
of fruit of something like that and then
I'm just taping the games so then I come
back and I got the first half is already
over I think that's what happened yeah
the first half was already over so I sat
down I watched but I watched Patriots
versus the Jets which you know was an
easy game what the [ __ ] I mean they they
did that their starting quarterbacks got
mono you know he went to the prom he
must have foregone his [ __ ] junior
and senior year of high school is
something I don't know the [ __ ] this guy
he got mono all my years of watching
football I never saw somebody miss a
game because of mono
he's got mono so he's not playing the
jet show up lovely new love the new old
school uniforms right those are the ones
that takes me back to Richard Todd and
free Mick Mick Neil and all of that and
I never thought I'd miss those because I
always thought the Joe Namath ones were
the cool ones but I think they got a
good thing going there you know every 20
years think they switch back I think
it's a good deal I'll tell you who
should never switch their uniforms
because there's only a few teams left
since the Browns [ __ ] up their uniform
they had that beautiful [ __ ] uniform
bruh how
why the orange helmet simple you know
indicating the history that they have in
the NFL how long they've been there how
few colors all yeah everybody's just you
know you look at hockey the original six
you look at Toronto they're blue and
white you look at [ __ ] uh the Red
Wings they're red and white
who else is the original six Bruins
we're black and gold Montreal blue blog
eight rooms because they [ __ ] French
they got to be fancier right and then he
had the Rangers they were red and blue
who else was the [ __ ] last one Jesus
Christ
the second is season ends I figured that
Blackhawks are they black and red I
don't [ __ ] know build shut up you
don't have any points to make all right
maybe you're right the Kansas City
Chiefs should never change that [ __ ]
uniform that uniform it's the [ __ ] red
and white very simple I also tape I take
the Chiefs first Ravens I watched the
first half I mean they're just scary
good they just are and this food I
bought the kid's name down that [ __ ]
catch that kid made in the corner of the
endzone oh no no what happened I can't
hear myself oh I see what happened to
[ __ ] there we go now I can hear
myself Jesus Christ I just knocked over
my whole podcast studio leaning forward
to get my phone here what the [ __ ] was
this kid's name here DeMarcus Robinson
Jesus Christ the hell did this kid come
from they think another guy is one of
the four to forty so I think they got
the offense done I I'll actually say I
think that defense is a little suspect
on the run but it's really early and
they got Andy Reed he knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing so I think it's I don't
know
first he's hilarious I [ __ ] love
virzi right by the waivers he's playing
Gotham comedy club this weekend all
right New York New Jersey Pennsylvania
the tri-state area you guys go in and
you support that guy I'm telling you man
he's [ __ ] murdering
I'm so happy for him you know as a
friend and that also as a friend I'm sad
because now he's never open it for me
anyway he's moved on he's a big star
catch him it got them now when you you
can say you sung in the intimate
confines of a 400-seat er no very happy
for him he sent me a text
classic virzi you know he goes big you
know he loves a favorite guess who was
he guess what he said about the AFC he
goes dude
the I'll [ __ ] read him if you don't
believe me I will [ __ ] read you these
things word-for-word three weeks into
the season Oh Paulie [ __ ] Mersey where
the hell is it scrolling scrolling
scrolling yeah this does every year
every year he's like the mush he tells
him that my team's a [ __ ] lock every
year I swear to God he does he does it
on purpose it's like isn't it enough
that you Giants beat us twice in the
[ __ ] Super Bowl you gotta [ __ ] do
this
alright he just texts me all right 343
oh no where is it okay 1044 a.m. my time
so it was 144 p.m. East Coast time on
Sunday Pat's gonna win the Superbowl
over already
defense is unreal Tom looks incredibly
incredible yo I'm headlining got them
this weekend all right yeah so I
mentioned that it's already over
everybody so I just wrote haha and over
all over already right he goes Super
Bowls over no need to watch does anybody
go bigger than virzi that's why I love
this guy I actually saw it already
defense is unreal
Brady looks great he's getting seventh
this year so I write back we've played
the Steelers the Dolphins and the Jets
now no disrespect to the Steelers I mean
I don't think they're as bad as that
first game but they were they seemed
like they weren't ready to go it was the
first game of the year did anybody can
ever turn their first game the [ __ ]
Dolphins
I don't think that they were this bad
since there were an expansion franchise
I mean they were a [ __ ] mess and that
Jets their starting quarterback you know
went to Inspiration Point
prom night got himself mono so we
haven't [ __ ] played anybody so I
wrote that I go none of those teams are
making the playoffs you will never learn
and I wrote three weeks Paulie he goes
doesn't matter it doesn't matter that we
haven't played anybody he goes you guys
never had a D like this early yeah we
did we did in the early 2000s we did
plus two great defensive backs we've had
that before and that Collin's kid
barring injuries it's over AFC title
game against the Chiefs now first of all
that's what everybody picked at the
beginning of the year that was last
year's he goes it's over he goes
congrats and then sent a champagne
[ __ ] emoji and my eye I got on some
some other party [ __ ] thing it's just
[ __ ] it's the funniest [ __ ] ever it's
the funniest there's so much more
football to be played who the [ __ ] knows
[ __ ] I mean look at that [ __ ] Antonio
Brown saga day-to-day what the hell's
going on with that that's the [ __ ] cuz
as much as far as he does this [ __ ] then
identify MUP with something great well
his theory on an Tonio Brown is that he
suffers he's suffering from some sort of
CTE during his career he wasn't like
this at the beginning of his career he's
quiet he just did his job and all of a
sudden he's just [ __ ] bizarre you
know what I mean I don't know I don't
know so I'm just talking about like the
football football ask aspect forget
about all that horrific [ __ ] that he's
accused of so as always Paul goes big he
tells me to [ __ ] you know I already
booked my plane ticket to wherever the
[ __ ] that they're playing the Superbowl
and I on the other hand I always go the
other way I'm watching the Chiefs every
week like it's gonna make me more
prepared to watch them play the Patriots
I don't understand why I'm doing it but
it's also like
you know I love seeing greatness in
Patrick mahomes is obviously at this
point is on his way to then I just want
to see as many of his early games as
possible and I really enjoyed watching
him play today I will say that other kid
though who plays for the the Ravens
unbelievable arm Jesus Christ he's got
it he's got to start using it though my
god he little he was running the [ __ ]
wishbone offense you don't last too long
running around like that
when they bring that bit when he went
for the two-point conversion he got
[ __ ] stuck in the back that hurt me
to watch so hopefully I don't know I
don't know I don't know what I what I
don't know [ __ ] about football I just
like watching it in spurts so right now
I'm taping the Browns versus the Rams
and it's exciting to have the Rams back
in LA even if I wasn't living out here I
like when they go back to the at least
the original city that I know I know the
Rams that initially came from Cleveland
but I like that they're out here and I
love that their [ __ ] coach is like
some [ __ ] prodigy football mind those
guys are this [ __ ] man there's nothing
better than a [ __ ] genius head
football coach you know I think football
is like the perfect game if you're an
unbelievable coach or just total [ __ ]
warfare moving your platoon out there
and just having the right people in
position I love that [ __ ] you know I
never know what's going on but when guys
like Tony Romo break it down it's just a
[ __ ] alright let's get to some of the
stuff that I did this weekend so here's
where I am with my act right now so I
did two shows it like the Cornett
theater and I went up Thursday night and
just ate my [ __ ] balls all this [ __ ]
that was killing the last time I did a
spot at the store and [ __ ] killed I
had a great time at the Laugh Factory
was just [ __ ] going then it took a
few days off and it's still new material
so I don't know what happened but these
I apologize the people that were there
Thursday night I [ __ ] ate my balls
and then I came back Saturday night you
know working with Pete Holmes
and I was supposed to go on last I asked
if I could flip with them and he said
cool cuz last second I got hooked up
with a couple of tickets to go see Guns
and Roses at the Palladium where Richard
Pryor taped live on the Sunset Strip
I'll get back I'll get to that in a
minute
so I [ __ ] went up and I just I opened
with something different
breathe new life into it I did 51
minutes nothing from my special very
happy and I'm doing a couple to three
spots this week I got a what do I got I
got the Virgil on I know where the [ __ ]
that is I got that on Monday and kind of
a hipster room I think I don't know
anything that I haven't heard of is a
[ __ ] hipster room I mean I've heard
of it I just haven't been there in a
while then I got the Comedy Store and
Tuesday in the Comedy Store on Thursday
and getting ready here because I got
some dates coming up got something in DC
and then I got my gigs down south down
south in the ACC country getting ready
to go to that Clemson game very excited
about that I have a little bit of press
that I'm gonna be doing going back east
to promote paper tiger if you haven't
seen it yet please watch it it's doing
phenomenally and I couldn't be more
thrilled with that
speaking of thrilled so I was supposed
to go in last I told Peter I got those
Guns and Roses tickets so he switched
with me being the cool son of a gun that
he is so I ended up going up with Josh
Adam my is from the goddamn Comedy Jam
in the podcast of 500 and we went up to
the Palladium and first of all that
place is [ __ ] sick and people were
smoking weed and [ __ ] so there was some
cloud cover in there you know or maybe
it was just the [ __ ] not a little dry
ice [ __ ] that they do before rock shows
I don't know what but it kind of was
feeling like you know you know the prior
[ __ ] the look of his special you know
I always think that when I go in there
and we got in there just in time and the
[ __ ] band went on about maybe 20
minutes after we got there
and just absolutely [ __ ] ripped
[ __ ] ripped filming this little I
mean little little for them a 4000
seater but that's the second time I've
ever seen him and I see otherwise and I
saw him both times on this tour and
everybody was just thought it was a
[ __ ] phenomenal show and I'm sitting
there looking at my watch going like I
got to go to the farmers market tomorrow
I gotta get out of here
they went on you know but I stayed I did
I missed the uncle I stayed for like
three quarters of the show and I had I
just had you know it's a dad thing
I can't be dragging ass you know what I
mean because then it's it's just you
know I don't want I don't wanna do that
[ __ ] all right okay no disrespect to
Guns N'Roses but I got to take my kid to
the farmers market make sure they still
got the radishes down there whatever the
[ __ ] you know cuz they sell out but um
oh my god were they [ __ ] good Jesus
Christ just [ __ ] amazing man and it
was so cool to see him in that venue and
also the seam on this on Sunset
Boulevard because all these older guys
always tell a man you missed it you
missed it man you know back in the day
in the 80s the scene on the Sunset Strip
was [ __ ] crazy and all that [ __ ] so
to finally see that band with a plate of
zillion shows was extra special so
thanks Stu Brian hooked me up so thank
you for that and and that was my weekend
god damn it that was my [ __ ] we can
lean back to back weekend so Iron Maiden
last weekend saw Guns and Roses you know
this weekend who's next I don't know all
right what else what else what else what
else yeah somebody are doing the podcast
right now cuz my lovely wife is in
watching the Emmys
because she's a great person and she
routes for people I on the other hand
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and she can't
watch it with me every time I go in I
just look at the TV and I just start
laughing there's always something
[ __ ] inverting Lee hilarious just
pick something the actor being
overly serious I saw this one guy was
just like I feel such an aura adults
adults freaking out over a shiny [ __ ]
thing right and then oh and white women
crying is my favorite that's my favorite
[ __ ] thing ever you know that's just
my favorite my favorite [ __ ] thing in
the world right now and the second they
start crying I burst out laughing the
same way I used to laugh when like you
know when you used to watch The Biggest
Loser and some guy talks about how you
know we quit eat double cheeseburgers
and he just in the [ __ ] jock or he's
just watching a grown man is funny
watching a white woman in like a $10,000
dress talking about how hard it was it's
just funny it's just [ __ ] I'm not
saying that it wasn't hard but just I'm
saying his father you know she looked
over his shoulder I think those tears
would dry up a little bit but whatever
then I always end up ruining it so I
just I I just want I just I can feel you
know what I mean it's like when I'll
[ __ ] you know quarterback calls a
play in the huddle and then he sees the
defense and he kind of looks at the wide
receiver and then he knows what the play
just changed but only the two of them
know it and it's gonna be [ __ ] a
quick little pass for a first down yeah
my wife gives me that look during the
award show and I know what that means
get the [ __ ] out of here and she's right
cuz nobody is doing anything wrong on
that night so not saying it was all bet
Sarah Silverman maybe laugh as always I
think she's [ __ ] hilarious all right
what else we got here oh so last yeah
kids boys one for you so I put it out
there I put it out to the universe and
oh my god I was talking about you know
seeing these all these [ __ ] homeless
people out here and it's bugging me but
I'm afraid to approach any of them cuz I
don't know if this is the [ __ ]
bipolar guy with this sickle you know I
I just don't need to be you know getting
sliced up on the sidewalk okay
but I want to help out how do you help
out I'm not gonna [ __ ] to a politician
cuz they can't do anything follow the
[ __ ] corporation's own all right they
got a [ __ ] foot on the back of their
neck so saying I guess if you're gonna
try and do something rather than be at
the pathetic you gotta try to get
involved how can I do something I said
that on the podcast people put me in
touch with this comedian Steve Simone
was always helping people out and I was
able to get some gift cards you know for
you know just a family a family that
just was going through some [ __ ] couple
of bad [ __ ] things happen and one one
of the two parents loses a job and all
of a sudden they're in dire straits and
very easy it took me two [ __ ] seconds
so there's all these great people out
there like Steve that are actually
approaching these people finding out
what their problems that you just have
to vet the person you know you don't
mean so you don't end up on an episode
of American greed please make sure cuz
Steve's you know he's on the level know
watch him he's probably took those
[ __ ] cards and went to the grocery
still and got himself a [ __ ] prime
rib sandwich he's son of a [ __ ] now I
know he did so I was able to do that so
you know when I put that [ __ ] out there
about you know I don't understand why
public schools are in the situation that
they're in
I do understand that politicians can't
make it happen it's a too busy yelling
at each other and all of this [ __ ] so
you know you just sort of bypass them
and go directly to the people which we
were able to do here I was able to buy
some supplies for some public school
teachers you know just do a little
little [ __ ] and you go out you have a
couple of drinks you start smoking a
cigar and you talk real loudly about
what you did just kind of what I'm doing
here but I'm just doing it because I
hope that you guys can do it because
those are you know it just bugs me you
know as an American to see fellow
Americans out on the street like that
you know okay somebody looks [ __ ] out
of their mind crazy I'm thinking okay
maybe they need they need to bring back
the nut houses or something like that
but like you know I saw there's one get
out of a ten Theo dam like that that
looks just like somebody's
you know you try to shake it off right
turn up the music blast the AC in your
face but it stays with you anyways so
we're gonna maybe try to start working
with uh you know Steve I know al
Madrigal and these guys we're gonna try
to start working with them and we'll try
to try to create a little [ __ ] alley
around the [ __ ] that'll be a direct
location just so you don't have to worry
about cuz like you know I like most
people have given the things in the past
and then found out that they were a big
[ __ ] scam I've had that happen at a
number of levels and yeah that'll make
you want to kill somebody you know
that's that's worse I don't know but
somebody going into your house is pretty
[ __ ] bad but whatever just you know
saying you're doing something nice and
you know so anyways put it out there ask
around you know I think there's an easy
way to just do a little something
everybody does a little something maybe
it'll help out I can't tell you it feels
better today than doing nothing
alright alright so 300 days sober
you know I celebrated that by watching
Aaron Rodgers talking about how great
his line protected him how he wasn't
sore at all and he goes I'll tell you
what I'm gonna go home tonight and I
knew he's gonna say he kind of like
stopped talking and there's I got [ __ ]
I'll say I'm go maybe I'll have a scotch
watch some game film cuz of there
Thursday Night Football
that [ __ ] killed me I was just
sitting there my mouth watered like I
wanted that and I don't just mean scotch
I want to do that old thing I want that
to be my Sunday I'm too old it never
happened for me lead an NFL football
team to victory
on my way to Canton Ohio right feeling
good cuz I didn't take any major hits
and going home to have a scotch and
watch more football I mean can you be
crushing it any harder than that guy I
feel like I all of a sudden I was
watching a [ __ ] movie
303 days no booze I mean I'd say there's
no [ __ ] way I'm making this I'm gonna
make the year but there is no [ __ ]
way I'm gonna go the rest of my life and
never taste scotch again I just can't
[ __ ] do it the thing is I can't have
it in my house I don't know how many
times I got to learn that lesson you
know so you know what I did I [ __ ]
you know I love root beer right
that's an old [ __ ] guy thing I love
root beer right so I was hanging with
Josh the other night the [ __ ] did we do
we went down and then I tied bond so
where's [ __ ] coming back to lyrics we
drive it back and we're like and he'd
been mentioned how there's this place
that has these [ __ ] root beer floats
that I was like dude I have wanted to
have a root beer float for like 15 years
I used to get him all the time when I
was a kid what I had a paper would I
haven't had he's go to friendlies and
you go and then that was my [ __ ] but I
get an ice cream soda and then I
discovered the root beer float and it
was that was the [ __ ] and then I don't
know what happened
I probably was too old and I ordered one
in high school that's probably what
happened at some point that's why I
stopped collecting football cards one
guy just said to me aren't you a little
bit old to be collecting football cards
aren't you a little young to be a fat
[ __ ] I mean that's what I should have
said but I know how to say that back
then I could have kept collecting cards
and I just stopped because I was like
all [ __ ] am I not cool I should have
kept collecting that's when I knew
everybody in the goddamn leak but anyway
you know me to fight [ __ ] cards I
would have
I've got damn 40 years with the [ __ ]
football cards do you know why I own
every year I think of the 1970s a
complete set of football cards and to
this date everyone's well I just take
him down and I just go through him and I
look at him and I look at the back so I
[ __ ] this just the 1970s that was it
for me as far as football and I wish
that they well you know what happened
was like the generation like Billy
Crystal's generation
I think when they had all those guys
like Mickey Mantle and Joe DiMaggio's
rookie card and all that [ __ ] and it was
just something kids did and nobody
understood I'd the the money in
nostalgia and then all of a sudden they
got older and those cards were worth
tens of thousands of dollars and they I
feel like that generation loved it was
the weirdest thing ever them loving
baseball in those cards that much made
all these greedy [ __ ] come in when I
was a kid and start buying up like every
year they just buy like ten sets of like
baseball cards and all that so now all
the baseball cards when I was a kid are
essentially worth or worthless because
so many were made and then what happened
when I started collecting again just
because I kind of fell out not knowing
all the players I wanted to start
collecting football cards again I walked
into a store that sold him and it was a
bunch of adults like me collecting like
going to buy him and there was these
guys up there and they were just going
through throwing out the common cards
and just keeping the star cards and they
just were just leaving them there on the
counter which to me was sacrilegious
first of all the common cards those are
the ones you love the best you know what
I mean like when you talk about like
championship teams and you really talk
like everybody likes a like old Celtic
teams that I grew up watching anybody
can bring up Larry Bird and Kevin McHale
and Robert Parish and Dennis Johnson and
those guys all right but when somebody
says you know Rick Robey
you know who's that other guy Eric
fernstaedt just those [ __ ] players
like oh [ __ ] I remember that guy I had
his you know basketball card or whatever
so whatever so these guys like the
innocence of that that a 1950s
generation and then just through loving
the game and keeping the cards and all
of a sudden they were worth something
it just it kind of
ruined it and then so when I went back
to collect them yeah I was adults and
then it you couldn't just buy a set of
football cards it's like how much to buy
the whole year they don't sell it
anymore I'm like why it was just because
a bunch of adults that have money
[ __ ] bought too many of them or
something like that then they would
deliberately make cards hard to get so
they would have value or something like
that and then the whole thing was just
perverted I just said forget the whole
[ __ ] thing but I used to love doing
that because Abele on the back of the
card they had where the kid went to
college when he got drafted a little
blurb about him and then they had all
the person's stats I [ __ ] knew
everybody I [ __ ] know at night I
barely and I can't remember anybody's
[ __ ] name anymore I just wish this
does anybody know can you just buy like
a cheap set with everybody's you know I
always loved to how the rookie card was
worth the most yeah I never thought you
liked the player if that one was worth
the most I never understood that it's
like all of them if you like the [ __ ]
player right I don't know anyway how old
am I getting all right let me do let me
read a little bit advertising here I
forgot the [ __ ] click over to the
advertising I'm supposed to copy and
paste it there no Jesus all right who do
we got who do we got this week who's the
poor bastards and I'm gonna [ __ ] up
their what he called their copy oh look
who's here
simply safe on average a Burghley
happens a burglary happens once every 23
seconds in the United States I can't
believe somebody hasn't bursted in here
while I was doing this podcast when a
home security system is triggered no
wait a minute
triggered like it's warning you that
there's someone in the house so the home
security system was offended sorry a lot
of the time police assume it's a false
alarm and the call goes to the bottom of
the list but with simply stay for home
security period that was the end of that
sentence what have the rest of the copy
simply safe has video verification
technology which helps police get on the
scene up to 3.5 times
master simply safe can visually confirm
that a break-in is happening that's
hilarious
he's in the bedroom smelling the panties
grabbing the watches that a break-in is
happening giving police precise
information about where an intruder is
in a home and whether they're armed if
you see these guys that break in and
they like make us sandwich I mean how
many houses in before you get that
comfortable so they all have so they
have all the information they need to
get there faster and catch a criminal
asap simply safe also protects every
door window in room with 24/7
professional monitoring there's no
contrast no contract sorry hidden fee or
fine print it's won a ton of awards from
CNET to the New York Times wire cutter
prices are always fair and honest
around-the-clock monitoring starts at
just 15 dollars a month and for my
listeners simply safe has a huge deal
going on right now go to simply safe
bird comm and get free shipping and a
money-back guarantee that simply safe
bird comm today simply safe bird comm
all right who's next stamps.com
everybody no one really has time to go
to the post post office your busy
who's got the [ __ ] time for all that
traffic parking lugging all your mail
and packages it's a real hassle man
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts that you
can't even get at the post office
whether you're a small office sending
invoices an online seller shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps comm
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any postage
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready just hand
it to your mail carrier or drop it off
in a mail box it's that simple with
stamps.com you get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses are tu stamps.com right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bird
that stamps comm enter ber bu are are
alright we got through it we got through
it and I want you to know it'd be so
much harder for a woman to read that
copy I bought my daughter a tricycle
this weekend there's a big dad moment
know if I could putting the thing
together
I forgot the stupid washers you know
what do you think I did you think I
plowed through hell no I took it apart I
put the washers on there's not gonna be
any leftover parts right I think still
already squeaks like the son of a [ __ ]
though I got to tell you and she
absolutely loves the thing and it's so
cool we these these cute kids who live
next door and they you know they're a
little bit older and they got old bikes
and [ __ ] like that
so she wanted to go see him and she took
a tricycle along with her and she said
to her friend she goes look look at
tricycle dad got me made my [ __ ] year
oh yeah
I'm telling you my kid's gonna be cool
as [ __ ] I'm gonna teach her how to drive
my my old f103 on the tree
my teacher are to change the oil my
wife's gonna take it a ballet class and
all that I'm taking her to [ __ ]
jujitsu and all of that [ __ ] oh that
reminds me of a [ __ ] bit I gotta
write everything down now otherwise we
have a [ __ ] bit I was gonna do about
jujitsu how do you spell it
without being anti-semitic
alright what the [ __ ] now new jokes 2019
alright here we go
it's Ju JIT now [ __ ] you what he wasn't
trying to spell kit jooge it s you or is
it JIT su jiu jitsu
that's not underlined oh yeah look at
that I've watched enough of the [ __ ]
Rogen UFC there alright so yeah that was
my that was my weekend and I just had an
awesome weekend just being home and all
that [ __ ] but I'm gearing up to get back
out on the road here so that's why I'm
doing all the spots this week so I'm
trying to enjoy as much you know dad
husband time at hall it was awesome
alright okay Pioneer hey Bill saw this
article not sure the [ __ ] is that see
you guys I swear to God just help me out
a little bit
hey Bill saw this article not sure if
you got to see it but I think it's
awesome that you made the list and that
you're are acknowledged in it as a
pioneer what is this burr would forever
be remembered as I feel like this is a
joke because remembered as a comedy
pioneer all because he was willing to
take a risk on a new company interested
in releasing his special little did he
know he'd be establishing his new model
for stand-up comedy specials in the
streaming era are they talking about me
what are you by any talking about right
I don't know what to speak okay I'm not
reading all this let me get back here
what the [ __ ] her friend no the company
we started was I started with al
Madrigal because we podcasting was
taking off and the businessman was
coming in and doing what he always does
taking all the [ __ ] rights and all of
that [ __ ] and we were like they we don't
need to do this so we started our own
[ __ ] thing and then that morphed into
doing comedy specials but we did comedy
specials with three other comics before
I did one but I appreciate it that right
there that's how a German Irish guy
takes a compliment thank you all right
am i a [ __ ] parenthesis I'm not am i a
[ __ ] I'm not just shows you know dear
Billy Cottontail hopping down the bunny
trail hippity hoppity Easter is on its
way
I love comfort I'm not a lazy piece of
[ __ ] is this virzi I love amenities I
love taking esteem I enjoy physical
activity and the payoffs of certain
discomfort
I enjoy physical activity and the
payoffs of certain discomfort what does
that mean working out but I don't like
pain and I don't get people who do
elective surgery the discomfort well
where the [ __ ] did you go with I think
we talked about working out the
discomfort involved in going to
hospitals needles recovery
I think UFC is cool but really why sign
up to get hit when instead you can just
grab a blanket and watch Chinatown for
the 80th time oh god I envy people like
you we just chill
I've played contact sports well you know
what then you paid your price
maybe you smartened up and I'm not
really that fragile but I'm not seeking
out physical beatings I don't like loud
rooms of morons
I'm with you not because I'm not social
but I just don't like them I understand
this guy or lady don't you think people
should baby themselves a little more in
the right way
do I sound like a [ __ ] cuz I'm not that
go [ __ ] yourself I love this person know
a lot especially as a guys I did a bit
on that a long time ago
anytime you're doing something that's
actually good for you how you know it's
good for you it's usually get attacked
by your male friends for being a [ __ ]
or you know other homophobic slurs start
coming out and all of that [ __ ] so yeah
that's when you know you're like doing
the right thing no it's great you should
get a masseuse you should meditate you
should take [ __ ] saunas and all of
that stuff you should eat right and get
eight hours sleep all of that [ __ ]
that's what you should be [ __ ] doing
it's boring as hell but god damn it are
your mornings great they're [ __ ]
amazing
I wake up every morning now at like
[ __ ] 7:30 in the mine why would that
be I went to bed I left that concert
last night at like maybe 12:30 or
something like that and I was up by 7 I
was fine if I had been boozing if I went
to made the farmers market better than
you know yeah yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry
thanks me I'll make it up to you I'll
make it up to you Jesus then just
[ __ ] hating yourself alright
guitar nails hey Billy freckled toes I'm
a 26 year old engineering student from
Texas Tech I like that what are you guys
what are you guys the you guys got it
with you guys you're not the rebels are
you I'm gonna make my confusing that
with somebody else I know Vegas is the
running rebels wait a second
Texas Tech the Red Raiders that's a
[ __ ] great name the Red Raiders I
want to say Wes Welker went there and
I'm a big fan of yours before I get into
it I just wanted to say thanks for
working hard on being the best comic you
can be and I greatly admire you stand up
well thank you so much so I'm writing
into
with a sort of musician's dilemma and
knowing that you yourself are a musician
Jesus Christ with the flattery I am a
dad who plays drums I'd figured it'd be
something interesting to write in about
I've been playing guitar for over 12
years and have spent most of that time
focusing on classical took guitar
particularly Spanish and Latin music I
really love playing that style of music
and it allows me to feel closer to my
ancestral roots at least musically yeah
I imagine that strip-mall you then drive
by it's kind of sucks the life out of
you it's also very challenging but
beautiful music so I find it rewarding
and worthy a worthwhile endeavor
learning to play the Spanish sounding
pieces anyways the thing about this
style of music is that it's very common
and expected to play with long shaped
and buffed nails on your plucking hand
while of course keeping your fretted
hand nails short as AG I have always
felt self-conscious about walking around
with these long fingernails as I
imagined and I know I'm projecting here
that they appear feminine looking oh
yeah no this is like this is some guy
[ __ ] you have to look at this and be
like is this gonna get me an unwanted
ass-kicking you know what is a nun
wanting ask because every an unwanted
ass-kicking is basically an extra
ass-kicking every at some point you got
to get your [ __ ] ass kicked
physically emotionally somebody
something's gonna take you out you don't
need to go out of your [ __ ] way to
advertise that you're looking for some
extra time who wants to do more than 40
hours this week oh that guy over there
with the shiny fingernails
some people get away of pimps can get
away with it okay but you gotta you
gotta wear really flashy clothes to keep
the bullies away anyway and they appear
feminine looking or when I shake
someone's hand and they see the nails
they wonder why a guy would have nails
that long yeah my in my head I would
immediately think you were a Coquette
with a long pinky nail wasn't enough
that you just you just [ __ ]
stick your [ __ ] whole grizzly paw in
there it doesn't help to that a few
years ago my natural nails were breaking
from lifting at the gym so I started
getting fake nails put on over at a
local nail salon Jesus Christ dude
you're [ __ ] all over the map this guy
my head spinning right now they're much
stronger and won't break at the gym but
it's always awkward
walking into the nails long as he is the
only guy in getting my nails done
are we talking about that's great you
can meet some women they're like that
probably well why why do you only get
one nail done Oh cuz you know I'm a cool
Latin guy that plays a classical Spanish
guitar you just like to come over
sometime right you get if you're already
crush I already know you're probably
crushing it now you get you know you
lift and see you're in shape you're
playing guitar we this guy should be in
a movie
I guess my thing is I tend to feel like
a weird that I'm weirding people out
having these long feminine looking nails
as a male especially when interacting
with women women if I figure they'd love
it I guess I just want to I just don't
want to feel like the terms of deterring
potential partners or dates by having
these fingernails on my hands dude did
you ever see the [ __ ] that Prince got
jersey the [ __ ] women that were
[ __ ] throwing their goddamn [ __ ]
panties there at him
it was the most effeminate straight guy
ever dude you you are going down a
[ __ ] happy trail of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
just gotta own it the problem you
probably is you feel awkward so it's
it's you given up a lack of confidence
dude if I could go back in time man I I
would do that I get [ __ ] Lee press-on
nails and learn a little [ __ ]
flamenco guitar flamenco guitar whatever
the [ __ ] it is come out there with my
[ __ ] blaze and freckled fingers I pay
one of those Irish songs in a [ __ ]
Spanish style
anyways do you think that's all just be
projecting is this something I should
even worry about or is it just a silly
concern thanks for reading and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah dude I think what you're
doing makes you cool and different but
the fact that you're questioning it is
is driving women away and you're
attracting an ass-kicking alright so I
think you got to own it you got to [ __ ]
it on you don't who gives a [ __ ]
especially now it's all out there and
everything people are afraid to bully
people and maybe they're not I shouldn't
say that but it seems like they're yeah
we just don't do I play guitar you know
but I lifted the gym so my nails keep
breaking so I get these stupid Lee
press-on nails and then they give you
[ __ ] you know and just yeah you know I
am a big fruit basket whatever you gonna
say right then you take out the guitar
you [ __ ] crush it you know well then
you go out you bang the [ __ ] chick
the guy that was to us make it was
[ __ ] make it funny there you go right
there
that's like a movie you could be living
a movie every weekend all right you be
proud and you be brave I think it's
really brave of you to have those nails
alright quitting computers so that's the
thing I think you just got to own it and
have a little confidence and you find
alright if I can get away with walking
around with my [ __ ] goddamn Frosty
the Snowman had I think he can get away
with a couple of [ __ ] Lee press-on
nails alright quitting computers dear
Billy no fun and he's having no fun I
work in a trade and I don't have to sit
in a cubicle so the rest of this email
may seem too [ __ ]
well congratulations that you work in a
trade and you have a job I some I
sitting in front of a computer even for
20 minutes at home okay that was a
sentence everybody I sitting in front of
a computer that seems like bad like
writing for a Asian character like 20
years ago
I sitting in front of computer even for
20 minutes at home I don't care about
YouTube videos and I don't care about
most social media okay
created a Twitter account so I could see
what you and Rogan were up to but I got
rid of my laptop and I don't own a
computer except for my phone which is
really basic that's that's amazing I can
listen to podcasts at work and have
email but I don't use it for fun I think
what you're doing is smart everyone told
me it'd be hard but of course that's
them projecting and I'm telling you it
hasn't been bad I read a little less
about sports than I used to I subscribe
to two newspapers and when I get the
urge to be stimulated I flipped through
that thought maybe on this fine day I
could be the one to inspire you love the
throwbacks and go [ __ ] yourself yeah if
I wasn't in this business I would do it
you know but I gotta be honest with you
I'm barely been on my computer for that
type of [ __ ] because of this instrument
rating I'm trying to get so I am just
hitting the books and writing flashcards
and I got to tell you loving every
second I'm really enjoying it you know
like I was kind of overwhelmed at first
and I was just like you know what I'm
just gonna [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
how long this takes me I'm gonna get
this thing and I'm and I'm actually
gonna I'm not just gonna memorize [ __ ]
I'm gonna understand this [ __ ] and it's
been amazing I actually got a kick out
of Andrews been sending me some pictures
of you guys trying to guess what my
little flight flight simulator looks
like at home it's totally basic I got
the yoke I got the throttle I don't know
[ __ ] about planes but I had to get the
plane controls and then I got I got the
pedals which I haven't hooked up yet and
then I just watched it on my computer
screen that's all I have I don't have
the chair and all of that [ __ ] I just
bought like a [ __ ] a basic desk that
I could clamp all this [ __ ] on - I had
it downstairs but uh I don't know it's
just I kind of got to move it out to the
garage is basically what it is you know
it is you married know the star house
could you get your fun stuff out of here
but anyway but it's been worth it you
know it's worth it's where I'm learning
it's not to fight all the battles you
know
my wife tonight I get to his [ __ ]
hilarious was I was in the kitchen doing
the dishes while she was making a steak
what has happened to me as a man I don't
drink scotch anymore I used to be the
guy that cooked the steaks somehow she
just took it over and you know what I
don't give a [ __ ] because I I was
cleaning up because I just made some
lentil burgers that I eat during the
week you know I don't know what's
happened they got better in LA too long
but she was she made that with some
broccoli and some mushroom it was
[ __ ] unbelievable then she made these
little strawberry shortcakes for
everybody you know to me and this is my
thing if the woman I'm with is gonna be
doing that I can I can take my stupid
aviation [ __ ] out to the [ __ ] garage
that's all it is
oh my god was that steak delicious all
right twenty-one-year-old
with skeleton in my closet oh Jesus
all right what do we got here okay dear
old Billy red painting but oh wait a
minute wait I forgot to play my theme
music Jesus Christ how do I forget this
every single
[Music]
absent melody from somebody else all
right there we go all right I'm a 21
year old guy with the skeleton in my
closet and it's making me lose sleep now
when I was 15 a freshman high school I
was sleeping with this 18 year old
senior girl good for you she kept the
fact that she was already in a
relationship with someone after we
[ __ ] a few times okay she didn't let
you know all right
I was ridden with guilt why she wasn't
up front but she told me I wasn't the
first person she did this with she told
me her boyfriend doesn't please me like
he should and told me that she sometimes
talked to him on the phone
while she's naked to another guy in bed
okay all right all right
all right first of all people are really
young in this goddamn story what the
[ __ ] on a red shoe diarrhea this
[ __ ]
first of all do it you are totally
exonerated of the guilt you 21 years old
it happened when you were 15 it gives a
[ __ ] she's not still with the guy anyway
she convinced me that what she was doing
was okay saying that the relationship
wasn't going to last anyways and my
horny [ __ ] teenage brain went along
with it of course she did for a year
before I told her we had to stop I never
spoke to her I mentioned it to anyone
again well that happened well there you
go
why am I telling you about my shitty
high school drama
oh no I looked her up on Facebook oh no
the other week gone now for shits and
giggles swimming for shits and giggles
you were thinking about banging her
again and see that she's now married to
that guy and has a baby on the way
I don't know if she came clean to him
none of your business buddy or if she's
cheating on him none of your business
buddy or if he knows anything about it
at all not yet buddy when I asked my
friends for advice it split half and
half about whether or not I should
contact this guy and tell him it's none
of your business dude
it's none of your [ __ ] business
there's a baby on the way
that was a long [ __ ] time ago she
might have changed she might have not
it's none of your [ __ ] business I'm
at a loss here bill and would really
appreciate any advice you could give do
I do anything is this just in the past
what do you think it's in the past
you were both [ __ ] kids I guess
officially she was an adult all right
she's got some [ __ ] issues I don't
know what happened to her as a kid but
it's not your deal
all right the fact that you actually
give a [ __ ] shows that you're a
wonderful empathetic caring person who
needs to get on with this [ __ ] life
all right now I'll tell you right now
you are a little weaselly the fact that
you looked her up on Facebook and you
not cuz you looked her up okay you said
for shits and giggles it's not why you
looked her up okay we all know why you
look tore up okay you would think hey
you know maybe I'll go you know swing by
the old haunt again all right nothing
wrong with that either all right it's
just the way you present it you
presented it like me and everybody else
who listens is podcast or a bunch of
goddamn fault we know good goddamn well
why you looked her up but it wasn't for
shits or giggles you understand me
private all right overrated underrated
underrated shortcuts shortcuts make life
easier
everyone uses them people need to stop
kidding themselves with their
convictions oh no no no [ __ ] all of that
that all depends on what you're applying
it to if we're talking about using the
Waze app man I don't mind that but you
know I don't think taking shortcuts in
life is the way to go it because then
what you're doing is built on sand and
eventually it [ __ ] collapses I think
if you're a sociopath though you can
live with yourself people need to stop
kidding themselves about with it I think
you are feeling a little [ __ ] uneasy
about some decisions that you [ __ ]
made and now you're trying to convince
yourself that everybody's wired the way
you are all right not saying that I
haven't made mistakes in life all right
here we go underrated Generation X
dear Billy the [ __ ] I'm 41 and I've been
hearing all my life about the baby
boomers this the baby boom was that and
now everything in news is about any
other generation all of us always
Millennials what about us because we
were slackers we didn't get blamed for
anything we didn't do anything is that a
good time I don't I don't feel like I
don't identify Generation X identify
hair metal okay
Generation X to me was grunge music that
took all my bands away alright what
about us Jesus it's bad enough we've
been parented and governed by a
generation of materialistic [ __ ] that
grew up in the easiest era of American
history no they didn't know they did a
lot of them went to [ __ ] Vietnam but
now media they also dealt with diving
under your [ __ ] desk no no no at no
time was it ever easy people it wasn't
there was always something to worry
about
everybody gets their [ __ ] sandwich the
secret is is putting a smile on your
face when you take a bite I'm sorry
alright but now the media government
television social media seems to be
geared towards either baby boomers or
Millennials yeah because they're trying
to make money off of them baby boomers
are trying to sell them you know last
bit of life insurance they can get and
[ __ ] health insurance and Millennials
they just blame them for [ __ ]
everything but they give it away because
they getting older now so now they've
moved on to that generation was it Z
where the [ __ ] is behind them and it's
glossed over literally everyone that
grew up in the 70s 80s and 90s I don't
[ __ ] vote but about well maybe that's
why they glossed over I'm about to start
voting for people from my generation and
the next election the next election and
watch how we end up resolving a lot of
the [ __ ] these people couldn't fixed and
Millennials don't care about yet I would
advise trying to do that in the private
sector and then as far as like nobody
talked about us because it wasn't really
any Wars going on and there was no
social media for all of us to whine and
[ __ ] and moan and complain so
Millennials they get a bad rap because
they were the first ones that actually
had their thoughts heard by the master
because of Technology all right
underrated hey Billy Burgundy bollocks
underrated for the week reversing into a
parking space why the [ __ ] do people
drive straight into a space only to have
to reverse out of it completely blind
and I don't know about that one and then
also I don't know you well then wouldn't
you be backing into it blindly don't you
have a reverse camera can't you look
over your shoulder I hate those [ __ ]
reverse cameras I'm not good at it
I like the Maris side [ __ ] mirrors
the [ __ ] one that's you know inside
your car is useless now the way
everything's designed you can't even see
out the back [ __ ] windows anymore but
I don't know about that I think it's
underrated because it scrubs a great way
to get the [ __ ] out of there but I do
think backing into a parking space at
your job I think if your boss starts
clocking that is this guy just all he
wants to do is get money and get the
[ __ ] out of here
this guy dealing weed it might might put
you in a certain situation alright
anyways that's it for the podcast I got
to go put my lovely little angel to bed
here once again thank you guys so much
for watching the special it's it's doing
the best anything I've ever put out has
ever done and it's really inspired me to
[ __ ] you know put this new hour
together and get out there and you know
see where this new hour of [ __ ]
horseshit it's gonna take me so once
again thank you guys so much and thank
you to Netflix for uh you know hyping it
the way you do over the moon really
really happy look at that Oh [ __ ]
Billy Red nuts is happy here alright
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on ya on on Thursday and
don't forget to go see Paul virzi this
weekend at the Gotham comedy club all
right I'll see you